hello everyone i'm chinning from harvard
today i'm going to talk about recent
work with boss and shin
on common supremacy okay
so let me start from the motivation when
the motivation is about extended church
turin thesis
which asserts that any feasible
efficient computation
in the physical world is in bpp
okay but this is like a
hypothesis we are working on yeah but
can we
but does it necessarily true like can
any realistic
model solve a problem uh beyond bgp
for example like quantum computation
could be a very uh
uh least legitimate candidate
to refute extended church touring thesis
in the sense that we know that
factoring can be solved in bqp
and while factoring people
most experts believe that it is uh
beyond vct
yeah but in the meantime uh bqp is a
theoretical model
uh that's because you're really uh
realizable in uh in the physical world
yeah if so then the extended charge
turing system will be refuted
but can this really happen yeah so can
common computation really break the
extended charge turin60
yeah so if we want to use a quantum
computer
uh computation as uh as a program to
refute
uh the extended charge to insist this uh
maybe yeah like trying the short
algorithm
solving factoring would be the most
promising way
but the the issue is like to really
demonstrate
the the power computational power of
content
using factoring it requires many many
qubits and this is a little bit
far-reached
from the current technology
yeah and also uh before we really uh
realize such uh such common computation
solving this uh
important computational problems yeah it
also could be the case that there are
some fundamental physical barriers
to build a quantum computer for example
uh like for most uh content skeptic
scepticist yeah like the noise stability
or the error correction issue in the
quantum computer might be
a fundamental physical barrier to really
achieve uh
uh scalable common calculation
yeah meaning that maybe bqp just a
simple uh
is simply a theoretical model this big
uv actually cannot be
maybe cannot be really uh achieved in
the real physical world
yeah so if people really want to test
whether common computer uh is feasible
it's like uh if uh extended charge
storing this is maybe is wrong
yeah then can we demonstrate it using
near-term technology instead of like
waiting
like until 2000 uh more than 200 cubies
can be improved
can we demonstrate this with a near-term
technology
so this is uh where content
computational supremacy comes
rule this is like a compromise between
theory and experiment
yeah so in the theory site we have a lot
of
advanced and interesting nontrivial
content of reason
yeah in the past 10 20 or 30 years
yeah on the practice side in experiments
recent years uh there are many many
exciting
results from big companies like ibm
google
or the recent chinese group yeah people
can roughly build like
about 50 to 60 number of qubits
yeah but most of the theory size uh
the algorithm there requires much more
number of qubits
so in the corner supremacy uh program
the proposal is to refute uh extended
charge turin6
in a nisk system uh the noise
intermediate scale content system
so in the nisk system maybe the novel
cube is just about like 50 or
100. yeah and there are many popular
candidates like random circuit sampling
boson sampling or iqp
yeah trying to propose a program
yeah like it's possible to demonstrate
uh to refute ect
uh using just uh like maybe a hundred uh
number of qubits instead of waiting for
two thousand channels
okay in this talk we are going to focus
on a specific approach called random
circuit sampling so this is the approach
used by google yeah and we are going to
study the theoretical foundation of
this approach okay and before uh
introducing what uh random circuit
sampling yes
uh let me just remind everyone with some
basic
of uh quantum circuits yeah so
the introduction here will be very
preliminary and should be sufficient for
understanding the rest of the talk
yeah so when so in quantum circuits
uh there is content states and uh in
cubic space
you can simply think of it as a sense
two to the unique complex vector
okay and the content gate is simply a
unitary uh
operation acting on an uncured state
yeah in a two cubic state it's like a
it's like a
partial i mean a partial unitary uh
applying on this uh to the unit complex
vector
where the rest like is applied by the
identity
okay and a content circuit is like a
sequence of
uh content gates uh composed with uh
certain ways yeah and you can also think
of a
common circuit as uh two to the
inverters and using actually in the end
so so the application of
content circuits on input state size is
just like
applying a 2 to the n by 2 to the
inventory matrix
on a 2 to the unit complex vector
so the result is still a two to the unit
complex vector
and because this is a unit vector so it
is
we can actually define a distribution uh
from this uh the resulting
output vector yeah and the distribution
is over
all the uh uh length and bits uh
string okay and the the probability
density is simply the square of the
absolute value okay so now we have
this basic notion set up we can describe
what is the random circuit sampling
approach
uh to demonstrate common supremacy and
this
is exactly the approach used by uh
google's a very recent breakthrough
okay so in the random circuit sampling
uh
approach uh it is convenient for us to
think of it as
a as again so there are two players one
is the challenger you can think of it
like corner skeptics
and prover for example you can think of
as google
yeah so the challenger will randomly
select some
gates yeah so this is just some small
unitaries
and maybe also pick an input state and
with a lot of generality you can think
of it as a
zero state and then the challengers send
these things to
google okay an approver
then try to simulate the circuit
because we assume uh in a honest
setting the prover is able to really
run a content of the content computer so
it can simulate
the content circuit so furthermore you
can be
able to like samples uh the output
string from output distribution qc we
defined the previous slide
so the prover samples many many strings
from this output distribution
and then sends back to the challenger
and the challenger want to verify
that this sample does indeed follow the
the output distribution just of c
okay so intuitively while this approach
makes sense
uh so so for example uh if the prover
has a quantum power then we can imagine
that it is very
simple for it to to simulate the
circuits so you can indeed sample some
strings from the output distribution
just of c
however if the prover doesn't have the
content power
yeah intuitively the best way
the simplest way for you to achieve this
is to simulate the whole circuit
uh with a classical computer and we know
that uh the
trivial way to simulate a
content circuit using calculator or take
exponential time
so this probably is not achievable
yeah but uh in order to really make
some uh i mean uh to to make this uh
reasonable we need to properly define
what do we mean by
like verifications here to make
everything
uh making sense
okay so to verify uh so so in this
if once we think of it as a connection
again
yeah we probably want a verification
process to satisfy
our few property
first we might want the verification
process to be efficient
such that we can demonstrate
common supremacy in a reasonable amount
of time
yeah because we wouldn't want the
changes to
i mean fully simulated the circuit in
order to verify this this might be too
inefficient
and we also want completeness meaning
that if the prover
does sample strings from the ideal
distribution through sub c
then the challenger should be a high
probability
and also soundness like if the sample is
coming from a classical device
then we want the challenger to reject
high probability
okay so given this criteria one of the
popular verification process
people are using like google is using is
called this linear cross-entropy
benchmarking
this is a specific
statistical quantity yeah and the
definition is as follows
the definition of a linear quad-centric
angle mounting abbreviated linear xcd
is defined with respect to two other
things one is the circuit
c and another is the probability
distribution over earn this string
p so the linear x d of
p with respect to c is defined as the
following
expectation so is the expectation of
your sample
from its distribution t and apply uh
like the the ideal distribution q sub c
of x
and multiplied by its normalizing term
yeah and this is the resulting uh linear
xcd
of t respect to c so to see
whether this satisfied the previous
criteria let's take a look
so only if efficiencies are actually it
doesn't
so notice that to really calculate uh
the or estimate the linear xdb of a
distribution p
you need to calculate q sub c yeah
so this actually takes exponential time
so this is
one uh that draws drawbacks but as uh i
mean
if the circuit is small this may be
doable still in a reasonable amount of
time
yeah and on the completeness side yeah
when we really sample from approval
really samples from
q sub c meaning that here if p is
replaced with q sub c
yeah and actually this is provable that
when c is random enough
yeah then the linear xcd will be one so
hyper will be almost usually
okay on the other hand if p is a uniform
distribution
then people can show that actually the
linear xcv should be close to zero yeah
and this good property is guaranteed by
the
property the so-called
anti-concentration of
content circuits that guarantee you such
a separation
on the specifics
and this linear xdb is then used by like
google
other people to demonstrate common
supremacy
using the random circuit simple approach
okay so after defining the
random circuit sampling and their
verification process the linear xcd
let us take a take a look at what google
did
so in google's content supremacy in
their cigar more
chips they work on the
2d nearest neighbor circuits so you can
think of that
they they arrange the qubits in a
specific way they
indicated in this figure and the number
of cubits above like 12 to 53
like this is the best they can
do at the moment and the gate
is added in a very specific way like in
the blue part
they add gates like in different layers
and
[Music]
and again it's also chosen from certain
examples
and in their experiments they are able
to run
the depth from 14 to 20. so at most they
can run
for that 20. so it's like 20 layer of
depth
okay and using this they want to show
that
their content simulation of such
circuits
with such a random gate set this
specific structure
they can achieve high linear xcp
and in the meantime they also assert it
is impossible for
tactical computers to achieve such high
activity
so what they really achieve is the
following so
unfortunately because the things i
mentioned before like the verification
actually is exponential time
so what they really actually can do it's
like uh
for deaf being 14 they are able to
simulate
up to 53 qubits and they get a line on
the
like on the left and for the uh
deeper circuits they only extrapolate
yeah
from their uh result of a shallower
circuit
yeah and they are they are able to claim
that
when the number cube is 53 and the depth
is 20.
extrapolates and gets the linear xdb
value
from their content simulation is able to
achieve like
2.24 times 10 to -3
so this look looks small but uh
holly clan is like for any classical
sampling it will take like ten thousand
years to achieve this
okay and this ten thousand years
estimation basically is from
like the case computer has to
fully simulate the compensation
okay so does google uh really refuel to
extend the charge to insist this yeah
so in our opinion their classical harm
is not very solid
like the ten thousand years estimation
is
based on like foley simulations
and also immediately after they
announced their result
other groups such as ibm alibaba they
also plan to have a
faster classical simulation maybe you
can achieve the similar things within
two weeks or
two days and to us
the the more important things like the
verification process they are using the
linear xed
is not very well studied yeah it is uh
there could be a chance that
linear xcp is much easier
than for simulation of a content circuit
yeah another drawback is also like their
verification is too inefficient
so their results basically is based on
extrapolation
so it is hard to imagine if they want to
scale up to
even more cubists
in this talk we are going to focus on
linear xcp their verification pro
process and to try to give a more solid
theoretical treatment
okay so to to study the university
we started from the from the perspective
of a
attacking genius fcb in the sense that
the google's belief is like
if you want to achieve high linear xcd
all you really need to do
it is to fully simulate the whole
content circuit but is that possible
to leverage the structure of the circuit
and the definition of linear xcd
so that we can still achieve linear high
xd
a high linear xcp without fully
simulated
now yeah but yeah there are two
difficulties
uh you know really want to make this
happen to spoof linear xcd theoretically
this is not very easy to analyze
like the quantity although it's uh
properly defined but it's
in general how to analyze for an
arbitrary circuit
and also experimentally if we want to
demonstrate there is a technical
algorithm the verification process is
also
difficult to do as i mentioned before so
this is like a
in the in the awkward situation that
if you want to demonstrate the the
if you want to spoof uh google's uh
experiments you first need to have a
very powerful machine so maybe you need
to
even use google cloud to refute google's
uh
quantum supremacy yeah but anyway
in this work we are mainly focused on
the theoretical side
so our main idea is to try to see
if there's possible if it is possible
not to fully simulate
the four circuits but also get a
non-trivial linear xcd bit
and our uh observation is the following
we observe that
uh the marginal of an output qubit
only depends on its likelihood yeah so
actually this is a very uh basic fact of
content computer
content circuits yeah so how is the
light cone so lightroom of output qb1 is
the
red part which is like the gate or the
input
qubit that has a path to
this uh output qubit so in this example
there is a six qubit uh
quantum circuit but the like of the
output could be one is only four yeah
so in order to calculate the marginal
probability of just less than
upper cubit we only requires like two to
four times
like totally electron size instead of
two to the n
like here if i took the sixth time
so in general for depth these circuits
because we only have a two cubic state
uh gate so for that b circuits
we know that every uh lycone is of size
at most two to the d
so actually for each output qp we can uh
calculate the marginal uh in time
two to e2 to z so when b is very small
meaning that we are in a shallow surface
region we are able to
calculate the margin of each output
could be very efficient
so intuitively if we can use this such
marginal
of each output cubie to perform some
biosampling
and analyze whether this achieves high
linear xcv
then we might be able to discover a
classical algorithm
that achieves nontrivial linear high
activity results
fully simulate the circuit
okay so let's try to put this idea more
concretely
like describing the classical algorithm
meaning so the the calculator
algorithm can be as follows so we first
pick some upper qubits
where they're uh like forms of disjoint
and of size l
so in a testing circuit this l is just
two to the t
and then we can calculate the margin of
each output between time
uh two to the l and then we can use
this uh marginal uh as an information to
sample the output
output strings uh biasly so for those
who
those output could be being chosen uh we
sample according to a marginal
and then we sample the rest uniformly
yeah so intuitively because we
sampled the output cubits following some
algorithm they're marginal
so they uh so the the the final
distribution we are sampling might have
some
non-trivial correlations with the
underlying ideal distribution
q sub c yeah but in order really
about but to really demonstrate uh this
algorithm is non-trivial
uh we need to have either serial
analysis or empirically demonstrate
the performance yeah and in this work we
focus on the theoretical sides and we
have the following results
so we show that the
previous algorithm as the algorithm
described in the previous slide
is the first non-trivial classical
algorithm that has
achieved non-trivial linear activities
in the shuttle surface region
yeah so our land syrian state is
followed so let's see
uh the on qubit that's the circuit and
the likelihood size is at most capital l
and the all the gates are high random so
this is also reasonable
assumption in the serial analysis
and the algorithm will output the
distribution p in time
uh polynomial n and two to the l
and achieve uh uh exit linear xcv value
in the following so this is a little bit
maybe
not easy to see at first scan how does
this scale
so let's uh let me give you a corollary
uh instantiated to
google's 2d circuit so in their 2d
circuits
if the depth is a logan then our
algorithm
is able to output the distribution in
time 2 to the
b square so this is some kind of quality
polynomial time
and achieve uh one inverse polynomial
linear execute
yeah so this is far better than
qualitative because
the the the classical hardness uh people
usually claim
for the render circuit sampling approach
is that they cannot achieve
uh uh even like one over two to the one
uh the linear axis so here we can even
achieve
one of the podiums but the drawback is
like here we are
we are only able to learn to
prove the algorithm or to implement the
algorithm
on the shallow circuit
okay so let me briefly uh explain what's
the intuition
on the line the algorithm and our
analysis
yeah so the intuition the key uh
ingredients
uh in our analysis is treating linear
xcp
as a random walk so we give a random
wall picture of linear xd in the sense
that
we show that the expected value of
linear fcb over
the random gate can be written as the
summation
of some tensor networks non-negative
sensor network
indexed by a random random works
path yeah so is that we can
write the expected value of linearity b
in the big exponential sum where
all the segments they are now negative
and it is indexed by half
of the circuits yeah so with this
render wall picture in mind the google's
noisy simulation
of uh content circuits
can be viewed as uh there's some small
noise
of applying on each gate yeah so
the summons well becomes very smaller
for all of them
yeah and and hence that's why their uh
linear xdb varies
it's a little bit smaller it's still
actually scales that's like to the minus
t
because uh the the noise aggregates uh
uh uh like a cross f
and for our algorithm or like algorithm
you can think of it as
we we put very very large noise on
on the output cubic we are not sure we
are not using
yeah so it's like for those paths that
touches
those uh chosen output qubits
it's like uh let's uh sum and it doesn't
being counted
yeah but for those uh test let's touches
the output qubits we are we we chose
then that part will be counted so
then for the lowest part if we have
enough uh
output uh cubic being chosen that
then it means that we we actually have a
large number of summations in this
random work picture
so we can we are able to achieve higher
uh
expected being axes
okay so how to interpret uh our results
yeah so all result is basically the
as far as we know it's the first
classical algorithm that
very specifically designed for linear
xct
so this shows that to achieve high
linear xcp
you might not necessarily to fully
simulate the whole circuit
yeah it's possible that you're just
using some
easily computable statistics and get
a higher linear non-trivial linear xed
yeah and also from the random wall
picture
we can know that actually the noise is
quite subtle
because we know that google's content
simulation is also noisy so that's why
they cannot get
linear xdb very very close to one so
maybe their noise is inherent
and it is too large and actually
it is able to to achieve a comparable
linear xcd
in a classical device so actually we are
we
yeah we have some ongoing world uh
trying to advance or always a lot less
and on the more technical sides yeah our
random work picture
for linear xdp could be also of interest
uh
to to get people understand more what's
uh what's the i mean
what's this uh this verification process
really does
yeah because uh because this is like
kind of like a trade-off where we want
to have
verification but it should also be
efficient but also have the completeness
and soundness property
yeah and linear xdb is the
the one being chosen but maybe it's not
appropriate
so to to have more understanding on that
is very important
and the random wall picture might give
uh more insight
good so let me summarize uh
or work with some future directions
so uh i think there are three important
uh directions actually very different
directions
but all of them are important and it
requires both theory
and experiments yeah and on the series
side
it is uh important to have more
understanding in being
executed because this is like the
computational catholic
verification people are using yeah so
the harness is really
based on linear cv being hard
for a technical computer to achieve
yeah so to really want so if you really
want to uh demonstrate uh
uh like extended charge student systems
uh can be refuted by a quantum
computation
it is also of you know i mean of the
same importance to understand
linear xdb better
and on the experimental sides yeah of
course it is important to scale up the
content computer for sure
and but also on the faster verification
and trying to see what's the limit of
classical simulations
also of the i mean of the same
importance in
my opinion because
uh if you because as i mentioned before
the the parameter region actually is
quite subtle
because in a common simulation there's
an inherent noise
and the whole uh program of corner
supremacy basically is to understand
is this uh error noise is inherent is
there
really a physical uh barrier to achieve
a
large scale uh like noise tolerance uh
quantum computation
uh so so to to see uh
uh if there's a comparable classical
simulation
like uh for the same or quantum
supremacy test is
important for us to see whether uh the
current quantum technology already
breaks expenditure in
transparency or not
and the third direction which i think is
also very
interesting is to propose new uh
quantum supremacy uh protocol so
the the the random circuit sampling
protocol now
suffers from the the limit of
verification like the verification is
inherently uh exponential
so can we come up with a better
constraincy protocol with a more
scalable
verification process and also have a
more solid complexity theoretic
foundation
yeah and we also have some
work towards this direction
okay so yeah so to summary yeah i think
uh chromosphere is indeed
a very exciting area uh like between
in the intersection of uh like
experiment and theory
intersection of physics and computer
science
and so currently it looks like the
external site
is leading there are a lot of
breakthrough in that
however the theoretical foundation and
understanding
in this consequence is very liking
so it will be very interesting if there
are more series
study in this and gives a more solid
foundation on this so that we can see
whether
it is possible or not to refuse or not
refute
extended church during this in the near
future
okay so this is my talk and thanks for
your attention